all right let's get started so welcome
everyone um we're really pleased to have
emma pearson with us today
so emma actually comes from
stanford well i mean not originally but
she spent uh her undergrad and
grad school at stanford
she actually took one of my classes when
i first saw it started
at stanford so um emma is uh has done a
lot of great work at the
in machine learning in particular
addressing fairness and my group has
done um some of uh work in fairness and
we always
go and ask emma because she's kind of
the uh our go-to resident expert on the
topic um so she's since graduated she's
spending a
a year at msr new england before
starting as an assistant professor in uh
cornell
um next year so
i'm sure she'll have a lot of
interesting things and important things
to say along with the general theme
that we've been trying to go for in
these
classes which is how ai really matters
and affects people's lives so please
take it away emma
thank you thank you for this invitation
it's a pleasure to be here um to be back
at stanford if only virtually and
actually to be back specifically in
cs221 which was actually the first
computer science class i ever took at
stanford so it brings back fond memories
and i'm not just saying that to suck up
to the professors
okay so today i'm going to be talking um
basically giving
a
two-part talk in the first part of the
talk um i'm going to give an overview of
some of the recent projects that i've
worked on um discussing sort of social
implications of ai and trying to use it
to improve people's lives uh and then
i'm going to give a little bit of a
story about how i got here just in case
it's useful to you as you're sort of
trying to unravel your own professional
choices
so at a high level as percy said i use
ai and data science and for very
practical applications and the specific
applications i focus on are reducing
inequality and improving health care
today i'm going to be talking about
using ai to study inequality in three
areas first i'm going to tell you a
story about policing and how we can use
ai to study inequality and policing then
i'll talk about using ai to study
inequality and pain and then finally
i'll talk about using it to study
inequality in covid 19.
so let's jump right into it let's talk
about policing this is joint work with a
number of excellent co-authors whose
names i will now attempt to rattle off
uh camilla yan sam
uh dan amy uh vignesh cheryl uh phoebe
uh sorry ravi and sharid uh so it's
quite quite a large project and the
efforts of a ton of people
so
why is policing something we care about
i think this year that point doesn't
really need to be explained right it's
obvious that policing has a tremendous
impact on communities across the united
states and in fact it's one of the major
leading causes of death for young men
particularly for young african-american
men
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about police traffic stops why do we
care about police traffic stops well
they're one of the most common ways we
interact with police tens of millions of
americans are stopped every year
and there's concern that traffic stops
may be racially discriminatory to be
clear about what i mean by racial
discrimination and i'll make this more
precise in a couple slides this is when
someone is treated more negatively
because of their race so someone is
stopped by police because they're black
they wouldn't have been stopped by
police had they been driving the same
way in the same car but they've been
white for example
now this is obviously very bad if it's
happening but it's hard to statistically
test for let's talk about why
so first challenge we confronted when we
embarked on this project is that there
was no unified data set tracking every
stop made by the police
rather the way data is stored is that
each department stores data in its own
little system in its own into a
syncretic format
and so we set about creating this data
set and we did so in two stages in the
first stage our journalist collaborators
submitted data requests to more than 150
police departments over the course of
five years this was like a colossal
amount of work for them journalists are
amazing collaborators
now of course now that data comes
pouring in and you have this like
nightmarish data standardization task
right where every every single data set
is in a different format so we put in
thousands of hours to clean up the data
and put it into a standard format
now the good news for you is that we've
made all this data available for you so
if you're looking for interesting data
sets on inequality or on policing this
is a publicly available resource which
is easy to download the full data set
tracks some 227 million stops made
across 56 city agencies so that's stuff
like the san francisco police department
and 33 state agencies that would be like
the california highway patrol and in the
main analysis i'll be talking to you
about today we're going to be analyzing
95 million stops the reason that number
is somewhat smaller is for example we
have to filter for departments that have
enough data to even do this analysis at
all if the department doesn't track the
race of stop drivers it's very hard to
analyze racial discrimination
so in our analysis we look at three
different questions we look at whether
the police discriminate in whom they
stop in the first place we look at
whether they discriminate in whom they
search after stopping them and then we
look at how policy changes affect these
things
today i'm only going to be talking to
you about the second question and i'll
do so because it's particularly
interesting from sort of a data science
ai methods standpoint but also because
the methods i'll be describing to you
are applicable to studying bias in many
other human decisions as i'll describe
so our police search is discriminatory
a little bit of context on police
searches so after the police stop a
driver they're allowed to conduct a
search in order to find contraband
contraband here means things you're not
supposed to be carrying like illegal
drugs weapons etc
the purpose of a search is to find
contraband they're not supposed to
search you just because they're curious
or because they're trying to harass you
or whatever
so because the purpose of a search is to
find contraband we're going to test
whether minorities are searched when
they are less likely to have contraband
at a lower threshold of evidence so if
police are searching white drivers for
example when they're only 40 likely to
carry contraband but they're searching
black drivers when they're only 20
likely to carry contraband those
different different thresholds that
would be discrimination under our
definition of discrimination importantly
this is only one way the police can
discriminate there are a lot of other
problematic things the police can do as
we've seen this year of course
we're testing for a very specific type
of police discrimination this is not
comprehensive
so first simple test of whether the
police are discriminating and whom they
search is to look at the search rates in
other words how likely is someone to be
searched after a stop and the results of
this analysis are shown for our data in
the graph at right state patrol stops on
the left city stops on the right we're
plotting the average search rate across
locations on the y-axis
and you can see that there are like
these very big gaps in this plot with
black and hispanic drivers much more
likely to be searched after a stop than
are white drivers
but this by itself does not prove that
the police are being discriminatory i.e
applying different thresholds on the
basis of race
it's possible that some races are more
likely to carry contraband drugs weapons
whatever
the purpose of a search is to find
contraband so if some groups are more
likely to carry it police may be more
likely to search them even in the
absence of applying different thresholds
on the basis of race
so a second simple test that's been
proposed to get around this problem is
to look not at the rates of searches but
at the outcomes of those searches
this is called an outcome test and the
idea is you look at how likely the
search is to find contraband we call
that the hit rate this was proposed by
becker and other economists it's decades
old it's a very frequent test for in the
economics literature
the intuition behind this test is like
look if searches of white drivers are
finding contraband 90 of the time but
searches of black drivers are finding
contraband only 10 of the time it
suggests that police are searching white
drivers only when they're very likely to
carry contraband but they're searching
black drivers on the basis of relatively
little evidence indicative of
discrimination
so if there are differences in the hit
rates by race that's discrimination
under the outcome test and when you do
this analysis on our data you do indeed
see that hit rates are lower for black
and hispanic drivers in both state stops
and city stops than they are for white
drivers suggesting discrimination
against minority groups
but it turns out that there's a flaw in
the outcome test as well and this is
called infra marginality and i'm going
to illustrate it with a simple
hypothetical example totally
hypothetical these numbers are made up
imagine there are two races black
drivers and white drivers and imagine
among each race there are two groups
those who are very likely to carry
contraband and those who are quite
unlikely
and these groups are easy to tell apart
you know maybe one of them is wearing
blue hats
so among the likely group fifty percent
of black drivers carry contraband and
seventy-five percent of white drivers
carry contraband among the unlikely
group five percent carry contraband
regardless of their race
and importantly imagine in this
hypothetical example that the police are
not being discriminatory they search
everyone who is more than 10 percent
likely to carry contraband they apply
the same threshold irrespective of
driver race
what are the hit rates for white and
black drivers going to be in this
hypothetical example
well the police are going to search all
the likely drivers and they're going to
end up with a hit rate of 50 for black
drivers and 75 for white drivers
so from that difference in hit rates
we're going to conclude that there's
discrimination in this hypothetical
example but that's a misleading
conclusion because by assumption we're
applying the same threshold to both
groups
so why is this happening why are we
getting this misleading result well it's
happening because the statistic we're
looking at the probability of carrying
contraband conditional and being above
the threshold
is not the same as what we actually care
about which is this
so these are simply different quantities
threshold itself is hard to infer
it's not directly measurable from the
data the way the hit rate is
so the solution that's been proposed is
to use a bayesian latent variable model
to try to infer this threshold so i'll
tell you about that now before i do
though are there any pressing questions
and also am i talking at an appropriate
volume
cool
so
the threshold test proposes a stylized
model of a police stop and when i say
stylized what i mean is you can never
capture all aspects of the real world in
math right your hope is that you capture
sort of enough relevant aspects of the
real world to enable you to measure the
quantities of interest
in this case the thing we want to
measure is that threshold at which the
search is being conducted so the goal of
this model is to estimate the search
thresholds which are consistent with the
observed data namely the search rates
and the hit rates
and discrimination just as before is if
lower search thresholds are being
applied in searches of minority drivers
so here's how the threshold test models
a police stop
we imagine that when the officer stops
someone they estimate the probability p
that that person carrier is contraband p
captures you know contextual factors
like the age and the gender of the
driver how nervous they're acting etc
and it's drawn from a risk distribution
which is shown graphically at right so
the risk distribution is a probability
distribution on the unit interval so it
ranges from zero to one
for example if the police you know pull
over a bus driver p is probably quite
low right because he's like driving kids
around hopefully he's not also like
burying weapons or drugs and so p would
be pretty low on the other hand if they
pull over a driver and he's like acting
woozy and drinking out of a bottle like
that's pretty sketchy p is probably
higher
now in order to fit this model at all
you have to make some assumption about
what the risk distributions look like
you can't fit arbitrary probability
distributions because then you would
have infinite degrees of freedom so the
parametric assumption that the model
makes is that the risk distributions are
beta distributions which is a very
standard distribution on the unit
interval
now if p is greater than some threshold
the officer searches the person and if
they search the person they find
contraband with probability p
so in the case of the bus driver he'd be
below the threshold and so the officer
wouldn't search him wouldn't find
contraband
in the case of the woozy acting driver
he would be above the threshold so the
officer would search him and would find
contraband with a 75
probability
the model allows the thresholds in the
risk distributions to vary by race and
location and discrimination as before as
if lower thresholds are being applied in
searches of minority drivers
now in order to fit this model at all
this being a bayesian model you have to
specify how you go from the unobserved
objects to the observed data so what are
the unobserved objects and the observed
data here
well the unobserved objects are the
thresholds which are the main thing we
care about and the risk distributions so
graphically that's the dotted line and
the blue line in the figure right
the observed data are the search rates
and the hit rates for each race and
location for example the search rate for
black drivers in alameda county is 30
and the hit rate is 40
so how do we go from unobserved to
observed
well i've shown this graphically at
right
the search rate is the amount of the
risk distribution that lies above the
threshold so graphically it's the amount
of gray mass you can also you know
express it as 1 minus the cdf of the
risk distribution this is intuitive
right it's how much of the risk
distribution lies above this threshold
the hit rate is what is the expected
value of the risk distribution
conditional on drawing from the gray
mass so conditional on drawing from the
portion of the risk distribution which
lies above the threshold what's your
expected value
so that's how we go from these
unobserved objects to the observed data
that's sort of the likelihood portion of
the bayesian model
to complete the bayesian model
specification you also need a prior you
need to place priors on your parameters
not going to describe that in detail
but basically in order to complete the
specification you place priors on the
thresholds and the risk distribution
parameters
now by combining those two things the
likelihood in the prior you can use
standard patient inference to infer the
posterior over the parameters
and the specific thing we care about is
what is our best estimate of what those
thresholds are given our observed data
now unfortunately it turns out the story
i told you is a little too simple and it
turns out that fitting a model on a data
set of our size is much much much too
slow and the reason goes back to the
fact that the risk distributions are
beta distributions in order to compute
the search rate and the hit rate you
have to compute the cdf and conditional
mean of the beta distribution and it
turns out that that is very slow
especially when you have to compute
their gradients this
which you have to do to use the m
the exact mathematical details of y i'm
not going to get into but the tl dr is
that fitting the entire national data
set is impossible and perhaps more
importantly the test can't be used by
people who really need it journalists
police departments anyone who doesn't
have sort of a ton of compute and a ton
of grad students
so what we had to do was replace the
beta distributions with a new family of
probability distributions called
discriminant distributions
and describing those distributions and
details beyond the scope of this talk
although i'm happy to chat with people
afterwards if they're specifically
interested in probability distributions
but it turns out that this new family of
probability distributions makes the test
run two orders of magnitude faster
and that makes it feasible to run on a
data set of our size
i guess a high level takeaway here is
that like probability distributions are
not just something you learn in cs 109
so you can pass cs109 they're actually
quite practically important and it's
worth paying attention to them and
thinking about what their drawbacks are
for now though i'm just going to show
you the results which is you know now we
can actually take this fast threshold
test and we can apply it to our national
data set
and so here what i'm showing you is the
output of this model it's the average
estimated threshold
and again we're averaging across
locations
and you can see that the average
threshold is lower for black and
hispanic drivers than it is for white
drivers suggesting that they're being
searched on the basis of less evidence
so to summarize what i've shown you from
this search analysis i've shown you
three results i've shown you that search
rates are higher for minorities that hit
rates are lower and that thresholds are
lower
this is sort of a characteristic pattern
for discriminatory searches you'll see
the same pattern for example if you look
at stop and frisk data in new york city
which is a very very obviously
discriminatory policy
all three tests here is suggesting
discrimination against minorities but
the threshold test is doing so in a way
which is robust to the statistical flaws
of simpler tests like infra-marginality
i mentioned that the same methods can be
applied in other data sets where you
have a binary decision and a binary
outcome so i just want to give you some
quick examples of this
for example we can apply it in the
medical domain to covet testing for
example where the binary decision is
does someone get tested for covid and
the binary outcome is do they test
positive for covet and if you see for
example that uh minorities who get
tested for covet are much more likely to
test positive then it's a worrisome sign
because it suggests that they're only
getting tested at higher thresholds of
evidence they're maybe being
under-tested for covid and in fact we we
do see some evidence that that is the
case so this is sort of a more broadly
applicable methodology
finally to close on the public policy
impact of this work um i mentioned one
benefit of using this different
probability distribution as your test
runs 100 times faster and this makes it
easier for journalists to use and in
fact that was exactly what we saw the
los angeles times was able to take our
faster test with some assistance from
our team and use it to show that black
and hispanic drivers in los angeles were
being searched on the basis of less
evidence
and in response to that within about a
week the lapd announced that they were
going to cut back on police searches in
response to these concerns over racial
bias this is why working with
journalists and other real world actors
is nice because they help you translate
your sort of research findings into real
world impact
okay so before i go on to the second
story are there any questions i should
answer
yeah um so we have one question
from a student asking um in india police
harass the poor
um based on how someone is dressed for
two or two-seated drivers for example um
so can this model that you've been
describing be applied based on economic
status
um
that's
that's super you know i've given this
talk like 50 times and no one has ever
asked that question that's super
interesting i would be curious to hear
more i there is nothing in principle
which precludes applying it on the basis
of economic status
okay should i go that's the only
question for now
okay uh cool all right so let's move to
our second story which is about using ai
to study inequality um in in pain um and
this is joint work with david yuray
sendal uh nco uray is a is a professor
here and he also prefers black and white
photos it would appear
okay oh he's also my academic advisor i
guess this is a relevant point
okay so a general fact about pain is
that disadvantaged groups experience
more of it um you see this for
socioeconomic disadvantage across a
variety of types of pain across multiple
continents across multiple samples it's
quite a robust finding and you see it
for racially disadvantaged groups as
well
and this is also true in the condition
i'll be talking about today knee
osteoarthritis which is one of the most
common causes of disabling pain uh in
older adults so mechanically what's
happening is that with the wear and tear
of time sort of the padding between your
knee bones the roads the bones grind
together uh and this causes a lot of
pain and it's like very common you know
odds are good that like multiple people
listening to this talk will develop it
so
in osteoarthritis as in other conditions
disadvantaged groups experience worse
pain
a natural explanation is like oh maybe
they just have worse
osteoarthritis but here's the
interesting thing here's the fact we're
going to try and explain it turns out
these groups have worse pain even when
we control for how severe the doctor
thinks their disease is
so i want to explain to you what i mean
by that but in order for that to make
sense i have to explain how we measure
severity and pain
so how do we measure severity basically
a doctor looks at an x-ray of the knee
grades it on a bunch of factors
and says this is a summary score so like
specifically you know they'll look at an
x-ray of the knee and say stuff like oh
you definitely have an osteophyte bone
spur um and you have these other
features like the joint space between
your knee bones has reduced uh and so
i'm going to give it a score called the
kelgrand lawrence grade that ranges from
zero to four
and it's sort of a categorical summary
measure where higher scores indicate
worse pain
how do we measure pain well you ask the
patient a bunch of questions like how
much pain do you feel when you're
bending your knee and then we take the
answers to those questions and we
aggregate it into a single score called
coos pain score so it's the result of a
survey
the data we're going to be using comes
from the osteoarthritis initiative it's
publicly available data
all the results i'm going to be
presenting are on about 300 people and
we're going to be comparing pain by
three binary groupings we're going to be
comparing black to non-black patients
and almost all the non-black patients in
the dataset are white and we're going to
be comparing lower and higher income
patients lower and higher education
patients
so what do i mean when i say
disadvantaged patients have more pain so
here what i'm showing you is a vertical
histogram with pain on the y-axis so
lower scores indicate worse pain
and i'm showing you the histograms for
black versus non-black patients and you
can see that there's a big visual
difference in the histogram where black
patients have worse pain if you want to
summarize it in a single measure you can
just take the difference in means for
the two groups and it's about 10.6
points on the ku scale which is about
two-thirds of a standard deviation so
it's a big gap
and the results for income and education
are somewhat smaller but still
substantively large and statistically
significant
the things i'm showing in parentheses or
the confidence intervals
so what happens when we control for
severity does the pain gap go away it
turns out that it doesn't so now the
graph i'm showing you right has severity
on the x-axis that klg score i was
telling you about before and pain is on
the y-axis as before and the important
point from this graph is that the orange
and blue lines are not on top of each
other even conditional on severity
there's a gap in pain between black and
non-black patients and if we want to
summarize the size of that gap in a
single number the standard way to do so
is with a linear regression specifically
we do a regression on pain of pain on
race and klg and that tells us basically
the size of the pain gap when we control
for that severity score klg
and i've shown those numerical results
in the second numerical column you can
see that for race for example the pain
gap shrinks from 10.6 points when we
don't control for anything to 9.7 points
when we do control for klg the important
point being it really doesn't get all
that much smaller right 10.6 is almost
you know as big as 9.7 it only gets nine
percent smaller and results for income
and education are similar so the high
level takeaway is controlling for
severity doesn't do very much to narrow
the pain gap this isn't our unique
finding by the way other studies find
this as well the goal of our paper is to
explain why why is there a pain gap even
conditional on severity
specifically we're going to try and
differentiate between two theories the
first theory we call the outside their
knees theory namely that there are
non-knee related factors which are
causing disadvantaged patients to report
higher pain even when their knee disease
is no more severe
and this isn't just some like crazy
theory we plucked out of thin air a
bunch of prior work points to some
factors that might you know might cause
higher pain and disadvantaged groups
maybe higher life stress differences in
access to pain medication differences in
how different groups report pain you
know there are a whole bunch of
possibilities
the commonality here though is that
whatever the factor is it isn't anything
that can be seen in a knee x-ray it's
something outside the knee
but there's a second possibility right
and we call this the in their knees
theory namely that there are pain
related ailments in the knee x-ray which
klg isn't capturing and if we could
capture these physical features we would
be able to explain more of the pain gap
so under the first theory there's
nothing to be seen in the knee x-ray
that would explain this gap and under
the second theory there is something to
be seen that klg isn't picking up
so why is the second hypothesis
plausible here are two reasons the first
is that we don't understand pain all
that well this is true generally it's
also true in osteoarthritis specifically
klg just doesn't explain all that much
of the variation in pain
and a possible reason for this is that
klg was developed decades ago in heavily
white british populations and so it's
plausible that it's not capturing all
the environmental or occupational
features that may be relevant to pain in
modern and more diverse populations that
may live and work very differently
so we're going to try and test whether
there are overlooked physical features
in the knee which would explain the
higher pain levels in disadvantaged
groups
this isn't just an academically
interesting question it's also a
question with concrete clinical
implications and the reason is that
whether you get knee surgery depends on
whether the source of your pain is in
your knee
if you go to the doctor in a lot of pain
and she looks at your knee and she says
i'm sorry i can't see what's wrong with
it she's unlikely to get you knee
surgery for an apparently healthy knee
she's more likely to prescribe
non-specific therapies like opioids or
other painkillers
in contrast if you go to the doctor in a
lot of pain and she says aha i know
exactly what's wrong with you you very
severe radiographic arthritis you know
you're poor on the kelken lawrence scale
then it's much more likely under
clinical guidelines that you'll get some
kind of surgical intervention
consequently if klg is missing true
sources of pain within the knee and
disadvantaged groups these groups may be
under referred for surgery
okay so we're going to try and test this
and and methodologically what we're
going to do is we're going to train a
convolutional neural network this is how
you know this is sophisticated because
we're using deep learning to search for
additional signal in the knee x-ray
which would explain the higher pain
levels in disadvantaged groups
so what does that actually mean how are
you going to search for additional
signal in the knee x-ray well the
standard approach to searching for
signal in a medical image is to train a
model to replicate the doctor's clinical
judgment to train it to predict klg
the problem though is that if klg
doesn't capture all the pain relevant
features we don't want to just replicate
it we don't want to set a ceiling of
clinical knowledge when by hypothesis
that clinical knowledge might be biased
or incomplete
so instead what we're going to do is
train the model to learn from the
patient by predicting ku's pain score
so to be very clear the input to the
model is an x-ray of the knees and the
output is a knee specific pain
prediction called alg-p for algorithmic
severity measure
and if when we control for this
algorithmic severity measure alpe it
narrows the pain gap more than does
controlling for this clinical severity
measure klg
it implies that the clinical severity
score is overlooking knee features which
might explain disadvantaged patients
higher pain levels
before i go to the results any any
questions about sort of the setup
okay
um it's in terms of comparing the pain
gaps between different factors like
income and race do we have to consider
overlap between the groups
yeah that's a great question um
there is overlap between the groups
there's correlation between all three of
these binary variables
each of the individual pain gaps remains
statistically significant even when you
control for all three at once
uh you could probably do an analysis
where you sort of controlled for all
three at once so that might be an
interesting thing to do here to kind of
keep the exposition as as clear as
possible we looked at each group
separately but yeah it's a good point
they're definitely correlated
great i think that's it for now
okay so our first result is that the
algorithm does in fact find additional
signal for pain in the knee x-ray the
algorithmic severity score alk p
predicts pain better than the clinician
severity score klg the r squared is
higher the difference is statistically
significant and you see similar results
for other predictive measures
but like those r squareds are really not
that high right r squared ranges from
zero to one if we're at 0.16 that's not
all that high
um and it's not the central question of
our analysis anyway which is does
controlling for the algorithmic severity
score reduce the pain gap
and it turns out that the answer to that
second and more important question is
also yes
so here the first column is just what i
showed you before it says when you
control for klg the pain gap doesn't get
that much smaller
but the second column is new it says
when you control for the algorithm
severity score lp how much smaller does
the pain gap get the final column gives
the ratio of the two columns so for
arrays for example you can see that the
algorithm explains 43 of the pain gap
while klg explains only nine percent the
ratio of those two point two numbers is
four point seven
the overall implication is that yes
there is overlooked signal in the knee
x-ray which helps explain disadvantaged
patients higher pain so this supports
the in the knees hypothesis
uh yes you should never fit a neural net
without doing a lot of robustness checks
um
whatever current computer science
practice may be uh and so we do a lot of
them i'm not going to talk about them
now but happy to talk about them more
later if people have specific questions
i do though just want to talk about two
accessory results uh the first is that a
diverse data set improves uh performance
specifically we compare training the
model on a non-diverse train set from
which we've removed all black patients
to a diverse train set from which we've
removed the same number of non-black
patients
um and so the size of the train set
remains the same we've just altered the
racial diversity of it and what we find
is that while both models beat klg using
a diverse train set further boosts
performance you get a better r squared
you get a bigger reduction in the pain
gap you see similar results for income
and education as well so to put this
within broader context the sort of ai in
medicine
there's been a lot of concern that the
training data sets may not be
sufficiently diverse um you know and
this is actually more broadly true than
ai in medicine this is true in medicine
full stop um and this sort of testifies
to
the importance of collecting diverse
diverse data
and then finally to speak about the
clinical implications as i said one of
the clinical implications of having good
severity scores is that it influences
the way surgery is allocated so we
decide to test how would using
algorithmic pain scores affect the way
surgery is allocated
now to test the way surgery is allocated
we replicate a previous study and we say
we're going to assume knee surgery is
given to patients with high pain and
severe disease so two you have to
satisfy two criteria
and we try measuring severity in two
different ways using klg the clinician
severity score and using alcp the
algorithm severity score and we find
that because alk p gives disadvantaged
patients higher severity scores it's in
turn more likely to recommend them for
surgery for example among black patients
roughly twice as many knees were
eligible for surgery when using the
algorithm's severity measure as opposed
to klgs
so to summarize we trained a deep
learning algorithm to predict pain from
knee x-rays our algorithm finds
overlooked signal in the x-ray which
helps explain disadvantaged patients
higher pain and a clinical implication
is that these disadvantaged groups may
be under referred for surgery
to put this within broader context of
sort of ai and medicine and ai fairness
there's been a lot of previous and very
important work on how machine learning
methods can potentially increase
disparities in medicine and in other
high-stakes domains and that's super
important
but we should also keep the more
optimistic flip side in mind that
machine learning and ai you know they
give us predictive superpowers and they
shouldn't inherently be a bad thing if
we're wise enough to apply them properly
specifically here we show how machine
learning methods can also reduce
disparities by detecting signal that
humans miss
key to our results here key to reducing
rather than two increasing disparities
is first the choice of the prediction
test so we didn't just try and replicate
clinical knowledge
and second we train the model on a
diverse data set and we show that that
contributes to our results
any questions about this before i go to
the third and final story
yeah so we have a question from
the first uh first section here slides
um so
can the bayesian threshold test be
applied where the observed data is the
output of an algorithm
the observed
uh i mean you would have to give me more
details but i'm intrigued i mean there's
nothing
it's designed to assess bias in in
decision making so whether the decision
maker is human or algorithmic there's
you know you could apply it to both i
would say
in the case of an algorithm you know
it's likely that you know
like at least in principle someone knows
the threshold right so it might be
easier to just like figure out the
actual source code or procedure behind
the algorithm rather than attempting to
infer it but there still might be some
algorithmic settings where you don't
know that threshold for example it's
some third-party company and they won't
tell you what they're doing and then in
principle you might want to apply it
here
and then on the on the line of
kind of
determining whether or not something is
discriminatory or biased um
what metric would you suggest for
testing if something like compass is
discriminatory
so how do you know if in algorithms
uh that
that's a big question i you know i i
would say
it is highly context dependent um you
know if you observe large disparities in
things like you know in the case of
compass you see these big disparities in
like fpr and tpr fall spots are right to
a positive rate um that should certainly
be a red flag that you want to dig
deeper on but then you want to try and
understand like why are these things to
rising and how can i ameliorate the
situation i don't think
i i would not say like in all cases use
auc and that is your golden answer you
know no i don't think so
should i go
yeah i think you're good to go
okay cool so um now i'm going to move to
our final story on inequality um this is
joint work with serena and with pangwai
so i'm a little nervous because because
palmer will actually know if the details
are wrong here um uh and then with so so
serena is a computer science phd in
ura's lab
and then
we also worked with uh jaleen who's an
epidemiologist at northwestern uh and
then we also worked with beth and david
who are sociologists and then with euray
who's a computer scientist so it's very
interdisciplinary work because we're
sort of studying inequality in copen 19
so intuitively it sort of draws on on
people in a bunch of different domains
okay
so as you know viruses like covet 19
spread through human contact that's why
i'm giving this talk remotely rather
than in person
which is to say there is an underlying
contact network which modulates the
spread of the virus
so under a simple epidemiological model
an infected person can infect anyone she
comes into contact with with some
probability
those people then infect their contacts
and then you get this you know sort of
incredible spread of the disease across
the network
so because this network is so important
to the spread of the disease current
models often attempt to estimate it in
some way so they can simulate the spread
of the virus but they often have to use
simplistic estimates of the underlying
contact networks because intuitively
it's very hard to know who everyone
comes into contact with unless you're
living in some kind of surveillance
state
so people do this in various ways they
might assume for example that anyone can
infect anyone so the network is fully
connected
or you might use some kind of network
which captures trends at a very macro
level for example an airline network
which connects city to city but doesn't
tell you anything about the network
within a city or you might use
historical data and say i'm just going
to assume that what patterns looked like
in 2016 are what they look like now
intuitively though having really crude
estimates of the contact network is not
enough for a couple reasons the first is
that we're undergoing an incredibly
dramatic change in human mobility you
know probably in any of our lifetimes
hopefully in any of our future lifetimes
also right we have these stay-at-home
orders reopening policies like
everything is crazy
and the second is that we often want to
find or ask very fine-grained questions
um that depend on mobility in a very
fine-grained way for example we might
want to know the impact of fine-grained
re-opening policies like what happens if
i open
i open restaurants
you know from 3 to 4 p.m on saturdays
but not on wednesdays or something like
this
we also might want to understand
inequality in infections by race or by
socioeconomic status due to mobility
patterns and intuitively if we want to
do that we need to understand mobility
at a fine grained level simply
understanding how new york is connected
to la won't be very useful to helping me
understand disparities in infection
rates within new york for example
between rich and poor new york
neighborhoods
so because we have to understand this
mobility network in a fine-grained way
our approach is a two-step approach in
the first step we're going to try and
estimate the human contact mobility
network and then we're going to try and
build a model to capture transmission on
this network so let's talk about each of
these steps in turn
so how do we estimate this network well
we're going to use cell phone mobility
data from a company called safegraph
specifically that data is going to tell
us how many hourly visits there are from
a neighborhood to a place what do i mean
by neighborhood uh this is like a census
block group which you can think of as a
fairly fine grain census area with a
couple hundred to a couple thousand
people
a place which i'll refer to as a poi
throughout the talk is a point of
interest like a restaurant or a cafe or
a religious establishment you can think
of them broadly as places people go when
they're not at home
so our cell phone mobility data set
basically gives us some sense of the
number of hourly visits from a
neighborhood to a place
so mathematically what we're going to
try and estimate is a neighborhood is a
network that links cbgs neighborhoods to
pois places so you can think of this in
various ways you could think of it as a
list of matrices a list of networks
where each network
each network represents sort of traffic
at one hour or you could think of it as
like a three-dimensional cube
where the dimensions are sort of
neighborhoods places and and time slices
but that's the object we're going to try
to estimate
the problem we run into though is that
the cell phone data that safegraph
provides doesn't actually provide us
with an exact estimate of that hourly
network
the data they give us for the number of
visits from cbgs to pois is only at a
weekly or monthly level because of the
way they aggregate their data and they
also censor it for privacy reasons
so in terms of the actual data that we
have we have the number of hourly people
going to each poi the number of hourly
people leaving each cbg
and then we have a noisy estimate of the
networks connecting pois to cbgs so you
can sort of think of it as the number of
people going out the number of people
coming in and then annoys the estimate
of the matrix linking going out to
coming in
now it turns out luckily that there is a
machine learning algorithm uh which is
designed exactly for this scenario and
which you will learn about if you're
lucky enough to work with pong we and
the other people in percy's lab this is
very much pangwai's work and this is
very fundamental to this to this project
and it's called iterative proportional
fitting
and basically it's designed for exactly
this setting it says let's imagine that
you're trying to estimate some matrix
and you know the row sums of that matrix
and you know the column sums of that
matrix and then you have a noisy
estimate of the matrix itself
ipf is an algorithm that will give you
back a matrix which is consistent with
those row sums and column sums and
subject to that constraint is as similar
as possible in terms of kl divergence to
the initial noisy matrix and that's
exactly the setting that we're operating
in here so we use ipf to estimate the
true mobility networks from the noisy
safe graph data
so that's a little mathy a little
abstract let's sort of give you a
picture
so here what we're showing you is an
example from the chicago msa
and we're showing you from two slices
two time slices uh the first time slice
on the left comes from early march and
the second comes from early april uh
after social distancing measures have
started to take effect
and the gray lines here represent the
number of hourly visits from a cbg to a
poi
so you can see two things from this this
visualization uh first is that the
density of the gray lines decreases
indicating that total mobility has
decreased from march till april
and the second is that most of the lines
are vertical indicating that people
mostly hang around their own homes and
that makes sense
okay so now we got our network
honestly if you didn't understand any of
the matthew that that's fine the the
main point is we have a network linking
pois to cbgs at an hourly level now we
have to put a disease transmission model
on top of this network uh and this
relies on a pretty simple uh
epidemiological model and i'm going to
give you a 30 second crash course in
epidemiology and then you'll know about
as much as i do about epidemiology so
let's describe the model now
so a very standard model in epidemiology
is called an s-e-i-r model and probably
some of you have heard of this if you've
been
reading the news
and the basic idea is that people move
through four states in that order
s-e-i-r you can't go in any other order
you can't go back and loops so how does
this work you start at the beginning
before a disease has entered a
population you start in the susceptible
state which is to say you don't have the
disease you've never had the disease but
you're susceptible to it
now if you come into contact with
someone who's infectious you can move to
the exposed state uh which is to say you
now have the virus but you're not
infectious yourself yet so it's sort of
in in your body but at low levels
now after some period of time you move
from exposed to infectious meaning you
have it and you can infect other people
and then after some further period of
time you move to the removed state which
is to say you no longer have the disease
you can't catch the disease maybe you've
recovered maybe you've died but at any
point in any case you can't catch it
again
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say we're at each hour of our
simulation for each neighborhood each
cpg in our simulation we're going to
model the fraction of people in each of
these four states so we might say in
neighborhood five at hour four ninety
percent of people are in the susceptible
state seven percent are in the exposed
state one percent are in the infectious
state and two percent are in the removed
state
and then we're going to update that hour
by hour
so we have to model transitions between
these four states
two of the transitions the last two
transitions are pretty straightforward
and boring and don't depend on mobility
we just say at each time step you have
some constant chance of transitioning to
the next step
but intuitively the first transition
that s to e transition is going to
depend a lot on mobility because whether
or not you get sick depends on whom you
come into contact with
so how do we model this critical s to e
transition
we assume that infections can occur in
two ways at cbgs and at pois you can
think of cbg infections as like you're
just hanging around your house but
unfortunately someone in your house is
sick and so now you're sick you can
think of poi infections as you went out
to a bar there was someone in the bar
who was sick and now you yourself are
sick
so we assume that the cbg infection rate
is just proportional to the fraction of
a cvg which is infected intuitively if
more people are in your neighborhood or
sick it's more likely that you yourself
will get sick
the poi infection rate is a little bit
more complicated we assume that the
probability of getting infected at a poi
is proportional to the fraction of the
poi which is infected times a poi
specific factor which is capturing sort
of specific features about the poi like
how big it is how long people stay there
um and so intuitively places that are
sort of smaller and more crowded are
more dangerous and that's what this this
part of the simulation is capturing
a nice thing about this model is that
it's relatively simple for each city
we're only going to have three free
parameters which remain fixed over time
in spite of the dramatic changes in
human mobility those three frame free
parameters are going to scale those two
types of infections infections at cbgs
and infections at pois and then we're
also going to have a parameter which
scales sort of the initial conditions in
the model what fraction of people
started infected the rest of the
parameters we're just going to take from
the prior literature we're not going to
estimate them at all and this is
important because it minimizes concerns
about overfitting
okay
how are we actually going to choose
those three free parameters we're going
to do what's called grid search we're
going to look over all possible
parameter combinations of those three
free parameters for each city
how are we going to choose which one is
best well we're going to take real covet
case data the number of coveted cases
every day from the new york times and
we're going to keep the parameter
combination which gives us the best fit
to real cases in terms of arma c
now in order to capture uncertainty in
the parameters we're actually not just
going to show results from that best fit
set of parameters we're also going to
use all parameter settings which yield
an rmse within 20 of that best fit rmse
and that kind of captures the idea that
like look our parameters are somewhat
uncertain here uh and you know we want
to capture that uncertainty some of you
might be thinking like oh you know i
think beijing inference or something
might be a more principled way to do
this totally agree uh please figure it
out and write to us i think that would
be awesome um and in terms of the time
period we're going to model oh but like
why didn't we do that because it was
computed it's computationally difficult
as it is to fit this model and so we
just weren't you know with that that
would have been a further computational
difficulty but i think it's an
interesting direction for future visions
and friends is only taught next week
oh nice oh so
hopefully
they did they understand the fleet stuff
at all whatever okay well you'll
understand it even better next week
that'll be great anyway um
but yeah but next week you can figure
this out for us that sounds good um okay
cool anyway we model early march to
early may um and the reason we choose
that time period is that's what was
available while we were doing this
analysis
cool uh okay so to make things a little
more concrete i want to show you just a
sort of video of how this model looks
over time is this actually going to work
praying okay
okay so what's going on here i'll just
talk you through the three graphs in
turn the graph at right is showing you
mobility over time this is not from our
model it's from the raw data the y-axis
is the number of visits to pois you can
think of it as a measure of overall
mobility
and you can see that it drops pretty
dramatically about three weeks into the
simulation so three weeks into march and
that's as social distancing takes effect
the middle graph is model output it's
showing you the fraction of people the
model thinks are in each of the four
states and it's a logarithmic graph um
and you can see that the fraction of
people in the eir states i.e those
who've had the disease rises over time
and you can also see sort of how
mobility is feeding into the model for
example if you look at that e-state you
can see sort of a very high frequency
wiggle just like there is a very high
frequency wiggle in the mobility
patterns those are daily changes in
mobility so over the course of the day
and that's basically telling you look
people are more likely to get sick when
they're going out in the middle of the
day than in the middle of the night
and finally that graph at the left is
showing you uh by sort of spatially
geographically where does the model
think people are most likely to get sick
redder indicates that a larger fraction
of the population is in one of the
infected states and you can see sort of
that especially red segment in the
middle of the city
and i'll return to that point in a bit
so
okay anyone can make pretty graphs does
this actually fit the data yes it turns
out it does fit observed case count data
reasonably well here the orange x's are
reported cases and the blue is the model
prediction and that you can see that it
fits the observed data reasonably well
uh even if as in the left plot you only
fit the model on data prior to april and
then see how well it performs on data
from april to may it continues to fit
the data reasonably well
this isn't just true in chicago that's
not a cherry-picked example it fits data
pretty well across cities
and it turns out that it also fits the
data better than two baselines that we
try comparing to but i think the high
level point here is not that we have
some super duper predictive model the
high level point is like look we have
this model that fits the data reasonably
well but also enables you to ask very
fine-grained questions so let's talk
about some of those fine green questions
now what are some of the questions you
can ask with this model
so this model is of
what would have happened if we had done
something differently what if we had
started distancing a week later what if
we had distanced to only 50 as much as
we actually had
it can help you ask stuff like what are
the riskiest locations the riskiest
pli's are there pois which are likely to
be super spreader locations because they
have a ton of people
it can help you answer questions like
what's the impact of different reopening
strategies what happens if you reopen
pois only halfway for example like only
to half of their maximum capacity how do
infection rates look like under that
scenario
and finally it can help you
understand why socioeconomic and racial
disparities arise and today i'm actually
only going to talk about that fourth
question the rest of the answers to the
other questions you can find in our
paper and i think there are probably
other interesting questions you can ask
as well um the basic point though is
because the model sort of you know it
models mobility from neighborhoods to
individual places in such a fine grained
way you can ask a lot of questions that
naturally flow from that fine-grained
mobility network
okay so let's talk briefly about
disparities so we know that socially
disadvantaged racial and socio-economic
groups were hit harder by covet 19.
higher case rates higher death rates
disparities are very dramatic that's not
our work that's prior work it's very
very clear very striking
so
there are a bunch of reasons for this
right it's not all mobility you know
it's stuff like pre-existing conditions
differences in access to care worse care
when they do you know get get into the
hospital
etc but mobility is probably part of it
too we know for example that if you are
of lower socioeconomic status it's
harder for you to work from home more
likely that you're an essential worker
more likely that you have to go out and
do these dangerous jobs and you expose
yourself to risk of infection
so it's interesting to ask first does
our model learn
that disparities you know flow in part
from mobility like can the model
naturally predict the emergence of these
disparities and second if it does can it
expose the mechanisms via which these
disparities arise
in order to study this we don't actually
have data on individual people so what
we do is we compare neighborhoods we
compare higher and lower income
neighborhoods for example and we look at
how infection rates vary
so a first result is yes the model does
predict the emergence of these
disparities based on mobility patterns
alone here the left graph is showing you
disparities by income and the right
graph is showing you disparities by race
on the x-axis what we're plotting is how
much likelier are people to get infected
so for the left graph if you're in a
lower income cbg and on the right graph
if you're from a less white cbg
and you can see basically that all those
boxes all the blue boxes are to the
right of one indicating that people are
likelier to get infected under the
simulation uh if they're from a lower
income or a less white cbg
so the model is predicting these ses and
racial disparities socioeconomic and
racial disparities on the basis of
mobility patterns alone
and because the disparities by
socioeconomic status are particularly
dramatic i'll focus on those for the
rest of the talk but you can see all the
results for both in the paper
so why is this happening uh well we show
two two mechanisms via which it arises
the first you probably already guessed
it's that people from lower income and
less white cbgs weren't able to reduce
their mobility as much uh they had to go
out more and this is probably in part
because of stuff like differences in
occupation they're more likely to be
essential workers
but the second mechanism is a little
subtler
and it's this it's that when they do go
out they go to places which are smaller
and more crowded and therefore more
dangerous and this is true even within
the same type of poi so even conditional
on i went out i went to a restaurant the
people coming from lower income cbgs
tend to go to restaurants that are
smaller and more crowded and more
dangerous and that's the second thing
contributing to these infection rate
disparities
so i want to show an example of this for
philadelphia which is the place where we
see the most striking disparities let's
see if i can get this to play
yeah okay so here this graph on the left
is showing you philadelphia and it's
showing you results over time and what
you can see over time is that you know
this big red spot emerges in the middle
of philadelphia
and where is that well it turns out to
be the place uh with the highest
population density so that's the top
right plot and it's also the place with
the lowest income so this sort of very
high density low income area has higher
predicted infection rates in our model
and that's happening because the pois
that people are going out to are smaller
and more crowded and more dangerous
final um implication is that you know
the model can look at sort of the
predicted impact of reopening plans uh
for people in lower income
deciles as opposed to the population as
a whole and basically what we show is
that often reopening plants have larger
predicted impacts for people in lower
income decile so for sort of for people
in poorer neighborhoods than for the
population as a whole so when you do
consider a reopening plan it's important
not just to consider the overall impact
but also the impact on poorer
neighborhoods
and in fact california is starting to
consider doing stuff like this like you
have to look at racial disparities and
reopening and racial disparities and
impact you can't just look at the impact
on the population as a whole this is
also good practice by the way when
you're evaluating the impact of an
algorithm you shouldn't just look at how
it performs on the population as a whole
you need to also look at how it performs
on different subgroups
so
takeaways um this approach sort of
showcases the power of fine cream
mobility networks we show that even a
simple model leads to accurate fits in
10 different american cities
metropolitan statistical areas we show
that it can scale
even to sort of large networks with lots
of places and lots of people
we show that you can because you can
capture these very micro trends down to
neighborhoods and locations by the hour
you can perform these detailed analyses
that can potentially inform more
equitable analysis uh to cobit 19. um i
think a general question that i would
have for people and i don't know if we
want to talk about this now or at the
end or not at all but like what are
other questions you might want to answer
with this model um
because i think there are a lot of other
things you can potentially ask beyond
what we have asked and i'm curious as to
your thoughts should we return to that
point at the end though i don't know how
we're doing it on time yeah we have 20
minutes left so maybe we can take some
questions now and then we'll move on
sounds good
cool uh so actually
if
you guys have working mics do you want
to read all your own questions
so uh my question was if you are able to
take into account the percentage of
people that wear masks
we are not that's a great question
you're uh your reviewer two three one i
don't know many reviewers have that
question we do not attempt to take into
account the fraction of people wearing
masks and i think that's an interesting
direction for future work
yeah hi i suppose this sort of um goes
along with your question that you put at
the end of the slide which is what other
questions you might answer with this
model
but um i was wondering like could this
model of mobility be used to analyze
like other mobility issues that don't
revolve around like health or
epidemiology such as how different types
of zoning codes or access or use of
public transportation and different cbgs
affect mobility of those neighborhoods
uh yeah absolutely i mean safer data is
very broadly relevant to social science
and other questions of mobility
and we're using it for other projects as
well it's definitely
a gold mine for for other other
yes and yes
i was wondering do you think it's
possible that we can make connections
between
like physical mobility between
cbjs and pois and whether that somehow
correlates to the degree of
socioeconomic mobilities with
ebgs
yeah and you might look at um
yeah you might look at susan athey and
uh against cow athey and gents cow would
be the names to look up but like they
look at sort of socioeconomic
segregation sorry they look at racial
segregation using safecraft data but
then they correlate it with other
measures a sort of economic opportunity
using work from rush chetty i think in
their paper so that's absolutely
something you can do i mean causal
claims are hard but it's so interesting
and i think that's it
cool all right let's go on then great
okay cool so so i was i was asked to
speak briefly about sort of how i ended
up on on this path and doing this kind
of work um just in case it was helpful
to people so i attempted to to write
this down
um
okay so you know i liked math and
physics and other
similarly nerdy stuff ever since i was a
little kid um this was a picture of me
dressing up as a chess board for
halloween um so you can tell i was super
cool and definitely had a ton of friends
and i took my first ai class in high
school but i was the only girl in the
class and i had a lot of less experience
than the boys
and some of them made fun of my lack of
experience and told me i was the worst
in the class so by the time i got to
stanford i actually decided i was not
particularly good at computer science
and i came to stanford as a physics
major and i did not even take any cs
classes my first year at stanford
but
in my second year at stanford um i
decided i should give computer science
another try and so i actually enrolled
in this class which at that point was
not taught by percy i don't know who
who were the teachers
no
mm-hmm
so that i think so and some other i
don't know i don't even remember who
taught the class i do remember the class
was awesome um and and and honestly like
i i this is not propaganda like it was
actually true i thought i thought the
computer science was super cool um and
that summer i started doing computer
science research in a physics lab i was
developing algorithms to identify
certain types of galaxies um but i
realized something was missing that i
thought you know ai was amazing but i
didn't want to use it to study galaxies
that were you know millions of light
years away there were too many problems
that were closer to home
and this was really driven home for me a
few months later when i got a genetic
test which told me i carried a mutation
that gave me a very high risk of getting
cancer it's called a brachia mutation
some of you might have heard of it
and as you can imagine this was pretty
difficult news to receive as a 20 year
old and i spent the next few months
being pretty upset about it
and during this period when i was trying
to come to terms with the news i came
across this paper out of daphne kohler's
lab she was an ai professor at stanford
at the time i'm sure many of you have
heard of her these days she's an
industry
and in her paper they take images of
cells from cancer patients and they
apply a computer vision model to try to
predict whether the patients will
survive
and these days you would probably do
this using deep learning back then they
were using old school computer vision i
thought it was the most amazing thing
and more importantly it gave me hope i
thought fine i have this cancer problem
i'll work on this problem with ai i knew
that i wasn't going to cure cancer but i
thought that working on it and learning
about it would make me feel better
understanding the things that frighten
you often does
and so i wrote to daphne and she wrote
back on new year's day and she offered
me a spot doing research in her lab and
i took it
there's a lesson i take from this kind
of tough period in my life which is that
crying is underrated or as gandalf puts
it in lord of the rings not all tears
are an evil um i i found tough times
like this one to be very useful in
crystallizing what matters to me from
that point on i became much more
intensely focused on what i wanted to do
in life
so then i graduated stanford uh with a
bachelor's in physics and a master's in
computer science and i decided to take a
job at 23andme which was a genetics
company that offered very cheap testing
for the bronco mutation which i carried
uh their test was so cheap that my
little sister who is then only a
teenager could afford to get tested and
learned that she did not carry the same
mutation that i did and i thought that
was amazing you know expanding access to
genetic testing in that way so i
accepted a job at 23andme
but about a month after i arrived at
23andme the us government sent them a
letter ordering them to stop selling
their health-related tests because they
hadn't gotten basically the proper
regulatory approval so they could no
longer sell their broker test which was
the whole reason i had gone to the
company in the first place and for the
entire year i was there i basically
didn't do any bracket research at all
which i think is another important
lesson like even if you start out on a
path with the best of intentions it's
very easy to get really derailed at
least for me and it's very hard to
predict what projects will pan out
then i went back to school to start my
graduate research i was still very
motivated to do cancer research and over
the next couple years i wrote a half
dozen papers developing ai papers for
computational biology methods
but i began to feel my work was
unsatisfying because i was still too far
away from real people's lives early in
my graduate research my grandpa who
carried the same genetic mutation that i
do died of brain cancer we were very
close that's us playing chess up there
when i was little and i wrote a fair bit
of my master's thesis uh next to his
hospital bed
the thesis develops new dimensionality
reduction methods like a fancy pca or
factor analysis basically if you've
heard of those things
for a certain type of biological data
which is important in cancer and many
other settings and work like that work
like what i was doing just felt very far
away decades away from helping people
like my grandpa which is not to say that
no one should do it i think it's super
important that you have people doing
that kind of fundamental research even
if it doesn't touch real people's lives
for a long time
but i began to feel that it wasn't for
me that i wanted something that was
going to help people in the short term
if i was going to be happy for the with
the sort of research that i was doing
so
based on sort of that understanding i
started working on data sets where each
row was not a cell or a gene or
something very abstract but a person i
kept working on health care problems and
i also started working more on
inequality that took me forward to some
of the problems that i've told you about
today studying things like inequality
and pain and policing and covid
which feel very concrete to me
looking back at my research i see a lot
of failures and wrong turns i went to
23andme to research braca and i failed
to do that i went to grad school to
study cancer and i mostly failed to do
that i've spent more than 10 000 hours
of my life getting a phd and i think
it's fair to say that many of those
hours have not made anyone's lives
better
there's a lot of time running down blind
alleys and even when you do have a good
idea there's a lot of time polishing it
and repolishing it to get it published
and even when you do publish it often
very few people read it and even when
people do read it does it actually
change their minds
a few months ago a man contacted me
because he was writing a new york times
piece about our work on policing that i
was just telling you about and i went
back and forth with him meticulously
trying to make sure he stated our
conclusions accurately i'm sure he was
very sick of me and when the piece
finally came out i read the new york
times comment section and it was obvious
that none of the commenters were
actually reading our research they were
just spouting what they already believed
and that is probably the project i've
gotten to work on which has been most
impactful
but even though i've spent so much of my
life failing to do good i still think
it's important to try and that's the
final topic i want to discuss i outlined
this part of the talk the night ruth
bader ginsburg died i heard the news and
i knew i wasn't going to be able to
write any more code that day so i
decided i'd just walk until i felt
better but unfortunately it got very
dark and cold before that happened so
you'll forgive me if this comes across
as a little moralistic or maudlin but it
wasn't the best evening
but before i tell you why i think you
should try to do good rather than just
making a lot of money i want to
acknowledge that there are students
watching this talk who really do need to
make a lot of money when you graduate
you have families to support you have
huge student loans these are frightening
economic times and if that describes you
i'm not going to lecture you and you
should please feel free to ignore this
bit
still i can almost promise that for some
of you listening to this talk there will
come a point not too far for not too
long from now where you will have a
choice between multiple jobs which are
both fun and both interesting and both
pay you more money than you could
possibly need as a young person that's
what the stanford computer science
salary survey shows for the last six
years i have data
and when that moment comes i'm asking
you to choose a job that makes the world
better and not just in some trivial way
and not just for the very richest people
i'm not asking you to donate a kidney or
storm the beaches at normandy or risk
your lives treating coped patients i'm
asking you to choose to make a large
amount of money as opposed to an obscene
amount of money it's just not that big a
sacrifice in a world with such desperate
problems where we've gotten so lucky
and i also think you'll find that you'll
get more enjoyment out of whatever money
you do make
if you feel like you earned it doing
something meaningful
the other reason i think we're compelled
to fight for good is that there are a
lot of people doing the opposite i don't
want to get political about this but i
think we've all seen just how
catastrophic the consequences of that
can be
so if we who are given the most power to
push the world in the right direction
take morally neutral or morally harmful
careers instead the world will slide in
the wrong direction i am only here
giving this lecture many of you are only
here listening to it because people like
ruth bader ginsburg woke up every day
for decades vowing to push the world in
the right direction to expand the circle
of people allowed to be in classes like
this one she could have gone into
corporate law instead apparently she had
a taste for armani suits she could have
bought a lot more of them
i think ultimately a lot of us take high
paying socially neutral or socially
harmful jobs not because we really need
all that money but because we've
internalized the implicit and insidious
claim that if we make a lot of money
we're good engineers we've made it in
life we're worthy of respect
we need to break that link we need to
redefine what it means to be a good
engineer a few weeks ago i got an email
from a recruiter from the big finance
firm and i responded the way i typically
do i told him i don't work for finance
firms and he asked me why i didn't want
to work with the best engineers in the
world
and i thought
the best engineers in the world think
about the social implications of their
work
the biggest factor determining your
impact will not be whether you
understand all the variants of gradient
based optimization although you like
should put some effort into learning
those both because they are very useful
and so pogba like won't kill me
um the biggest factor determining your
impact will be the problems you choose
to work on that's what makes a great
engineer
i'll close with a quote from tanahisi
coats between the world and me which is
a letter he writes to his son who is
about your age he writes i would have
you be a conscious citizen of this
terrible and beautiful world
this is what i would wish for my child
and for my students and for myself
and for you as well thanks very much for
listening and i'm happy to take any
further questions
uh hi well thank you very much this was
impressive listening to you um well i
was i was thinking while you were
talking about this
medical
impact
and how to study that
especially
with regards to
the bias
uh population so um
there are quite a lot of actually uh
biases cognitive biases that
doctors can
can show while taking important medical
decisions
are we able to study somehow i mean how
they
[Music]
how this happens so
just to help them avoid and
eliminate or reduce this
this kind of risk
yeah totally i mean i think this sort of
like behavioral economics approach to
like let's understand doctors biases and
put them in in terms of sort of these
common
heuristics that people use these common
biases that people have um is a broad
and promising line of research
i'm not in a behavioral economist
for one example of this type of work i
would point you to
it's a recent paper it's called like who
gets tested for heart attack and who
should be um and it sort of studies you
know how do these cognitive
uh heuristics that people use play into
decisions like this the authors are you
should look for senator milanathan and z
at obermeyer and there may be some other
authors as well but but the broad answer
to your question is yes you know you can
you can absolutely study doctor's biases
in terms of sort of things we know
cognitively about people and they make
decisions
thank you
the other uh read out your question
i'm sure yeah just about the
the difference between racism
is um i'm not sure if any study
actually um
about us if any difference between you
know iq happiness
is what actually caused the difference
or there's a difference as a i guess it
becomes either correlation or
consequence
is there any
study looking deeper on us
to understand the difference
uh
i mean there are a lot of differences
looking in a lot of studies looking at
differences by race and ethnicity uh
this is a fraught topic it you know some
of the studies have not been good
studies like so like in particular
studies of racial differences in iq i
think it's a very fraught topic and then
there's stuff which is you know not at
all fraud like let's look at racial
differences and i don't know incidents
of breast cancer or deaths from breast
cancer so yes i mean there's there's
there's a lot of
research in this area um
of varying quality uh but a lot of it is
super important
it is extremely difficult to figure out
causality here and more studies that
claim right they can are
pushing a particular
political agenda and should be treated
for a lot of skepticism
okay thank you
okay
uh
since we are about time
yeah sounds good so if there's no other
questions uh let's uh
um if you can mute and clap that would
be great i'll count to three so we can
all uh give him a really big round of
applause that was an amazing talk
thank you it's a pleasure thank you for
the great questions
you